هذا رائع جدًا، يُسمى Moxie،
إنها أداة لتوليد الأكسجين تم
ربطها برحلة على متن مركبة Mars
Rover المثابرة وما يعنيه هذا هو أن هذه
الأداة الصغيرة أثبتت أنه يمكنك
استخراج الأكسجين بنجاح من
الغلاف الجوي للمريخ، عفوًا، استخراج
الأكسجين من هذا الغلاف الجوي و  ثم
تحويله إلى أكسجين قابل للتنفس ليتنفسه
رواد الفضاء أو حتى تحويله
إلى وقود لرواد الفضاء المستقبليين على المريخ
للعودة إلى الأرض، وهذا هو نوع
التكنولوجيا التي كانت دائمًا
في عالم الخيال العلمي الذي فريق
العلماء في  لقد أثبت معهد ماساتشوستس للتكنولوجيا (MIT) الذي صنع هذا
الشيء للتو أنه يمكنك القيام بذلك
ولذا فإن وكالة ناسا سعيدة للغاية
بهذا لأنك تعرف ما يعنيه هذا
هو أنهم يريدون تجربة
العيش خارج الأرض في المستقبل سواء كان ذلك على
سطح القمر أو الأرض.
الأمل هو أنه يمكنك الآن أخذ
أداة Moxie هذه والتي كانت
مجرد فكرة توضيحية وتحويلها
إلى شيء يمكنه توليد
الأكسجين لرواد الفضاء للتنفس
ولصنع الوقود الصاروخي لإعادتهم إلى
الوطن من القمر والمريخ.  إنها حقًا
تقنية رائدة هنا، حيث أن
معهد ماساتشوستس للتكنولوجيا التابع لناسا ورواد الفضاء الذين يطمحون للذهاب إلى
القمر والمريخ متحمسون جدًا
لها